but you know you'd hope that no one ever
finds this stuff i mean if people found
your stuff would you be mortified
um
i think that's part of the letting go of
perfectionism
i think i think when i was in my 20s
absolutely even most most of my 30s but
i think now like
if i if someone found it honestly the
only thing i think is like if someone
reads this it's because i'm dead
right and who cares if you're a dad and
then i go like oh i want them to know
authentic me
oh wow
and i'll go dark for a second my mom
passed away 10 years ago
and
her journal is one of the only things i
have left
um we all had it she wrote on a computer
because she was like very pragmatic and
like
and she
she wrote a lot about the cattle that
she raised which was not
super personal and you had a cattle
ranch in montana they had one right
yeah yep but like interspersed in
between like weights and like what
cattle were doing well and what weren't
um
there would be these little moments
where she'd be like i spoke to cassidy
today and she sounds happy
you know or like i don't know i just i
loved getting to
to see those little moments of her so
you know maybe maybe this is all coming
to me now that i'm a new mom but
um i hope gigi has like
i don't know
she rates my journals first of all i
hope she has a
10 years to do so because there's a lot
of them but
i think it'll be cool for her to read
my weird mind but it sounds like it
meant a lot to you to hear your mom's
non-sequiturs of these random thoughts
of you that you were on her mind that
you were totally so that's
that's pretty badass
yeah
yeah so keep writing in code if you have
to okay but i think i think it's
important